you have a charity right they do yeah
yeah it's called Patriots Hall of
Dripping Springs and it's uh out out in
Texas where we are it's 10 acre Retreat
and it's for veterans and families to
come together and connect and you know
there's a resource base for them there's
obstacle course fishing pond all these
things that wow um there's so many
veterans and families in Texas the
densest amount is actually kind of right
where we're in the center of and just
for them to get off the computers and
get off things like that and actually
come together and you know cook and get
therapy all these kind of things so that
was our my brainchild and then the
community has just stepped up I mean
it's amazing when you ask Community not
government and corporations can you give
to this and it's just changed our entire
Community they're so involved and it's
yeah
I love that mentality of having the
community and I think I grew up in a
small town in Texas and it's like I'm
used to that that's a really cool thing
you're doing thank you for sharing that
just so we can spread the word
[Music]
[Applause]